Michael 12 years ago I had a devastating
stroke
a devastating stroke how long 12 years
ago what happened uh well uh
I went to bed one night with Jennifer
and uh I woke up in the middle of the
night with a really bad headache really
bad headache went in urinated went back
to bed
got up that morning I had a uh job that
I was starting the next day
and I opened up my script to look at my
script and I couldn't read it it was
like Chinese I couldn't read it
I was like Jennifer
I can't read this I can't read this what
do you mean you can't read it I can't
read it I can't read this and she said
uh okay she knew immediately that
something was on thank God for Jennifer
because she immediately like you know
called my doctor uh drove me to uh
a Cedars I think it was Cedars
and at that time Michael I didn't know
my children's name I didn't know uh my
uh I didn't know who the president was
uh I think it was Obama were you
terrified no I was in a kind of a
floating thing but what happened Michael
is I got
right 50 of my memory back pretty
quickly
but it's taken uh
uh
till right before covered that all of my
memories come back when you have a
stroke and your brain Tears like that it
it it he it will heal itself your brain
will heal itself and but it takes a long
time and it's very very very frustrating
so names places streets uh uh numbers uh
being able to navigate
um I really did not uh did not feel
um like I was back and and when I act
for instance I have to I have to act
like I've always acted I listen to you
and Michael talk about hearing things on
headphones and stuff like that and yeah
I totally respect that and I get it but
for me if I can't be the way that I used
to be it it's not fulfilling if
somebody's got to feed me lines or
something like that I just I don't I
don't like it
and so ten years ago that's uh 12 years
ago that's you know what's really
stopped working I mean did I work yeah I
worked here and there but that's when I
started doing the Comic Cons because I
have a uh
19 year old son now he was 12 at the
time or not not 19 minus 12 whatever
that is and I and and my son um dassel
and so I still I had bills to pay and so
um it has to work uh I had to work and I
worked on a lot of stuff that that they
would pay me
you know quite a bit of money to come in
and do like three days uh or not three
days like one day or two days and then
they use my name and stamp it up there
and put it up oh Michael Bean you know
picture of me with a gun or something on
the front of the thing right and then
you know slowly but surely you're you
you go down and um
um I'm out of that now I did
um I did Mandalorian which was I didn't
have a lot of dialogue in that but I did
The Walking Dead recently and Walking
Dead I had about nine pages I had about
nine pages that I had to do and for me
Michael I I don't like to be the person
I think I mentioned this earlier I don't
like to be the person when when you're
doing a shot there are a lot of elements
involved there's the DP looking at stuff
there's a camera operator this that this
got his job there's a focus camera sound
there's all that kind of stuff any any
one of those elements can up a shot
and it's highly important to me that I
don't up a shot by going uh sorry I
forgot my line it's highly important to
me so you go over these lines hundreds
and hundreds of times if not thousands
yeah